My name is Howard and I’m from the Philippines.
My company is called Mochibits
and our game is called “Bounce.io”
After the bootcamp, we realised a lot of things
we thought worked in the game, didn’t.
The program boosted our skills as a developer
by helping us see things from the user’s side better.
We got feedback from mentors
on how to think like a user
and how to observe users better.
One of our games which was having trouble
getting good reviews and downloads,
basically jumped up to a 4.7 star rating
after getting some feedback
of what to do with the game.
Another game got featured and was able to get
a good number of downloads and reviews.
I would recommend this program
to other indie developers because
any indie developer, no matter how good
they are at their craft, can still get better.
It’s basically training you never thought you needed.
Nothing could be better than that
for people who want to get better.